Jackson's barkis Chris with a rebound
did you see daunted smile right
afterwards like yeah you got me
Bowman comes away with the old or behind
the play you got something going on this
isn't good marques Chris dodge dodge
hitch like 10 feet just that this lot of
smart people got in the way of this
escalating I saw dodge it smile on him
after he blocked his shot that was maybe
a hostile smile because they got tangled
up and then marquise Chris just
unleashed a monster push Marquis said
you know go to replay I promise you you
can't you'll take a look at what
happened here and believe me the
officials will you have you had bodies
flying old Marquis Chris adjusts and he
reacted to something he saying Dantas
must have done something first here's
the rebound Don citizen is trying to
swipe down at it you see Chris smile at
him they're like yeah I see what you're
doing you're just trying to antagonize
irritate me and here here comes the pus
watch this body Harmon and the two hands
shove but as you said that happened on
the initial swipe on the rebound
then the porzingis swipe on the rebound
and there's no punches there it's just
it's a two-hand show look at draymond
Green other things just I like this I
want all the smoke I wish I was in the
game the